hello
and welcome to next on air and welcome
to our
session on managing enterprise scale
distributed business and operations on
google cloud
before we jump into our exciting talk
today let me take a moment
to introduce ourselves i am anand
sundarajan
and managed to go to market function for
telco
media entertainment and gaming in the
google cloud professional services
i am joined by ven subramanian director
of engineering at unity
who has been instrumental in unity's
migration into gcp
i also have som roy who heads our
professional services team
in the san francisco region in this
session we will walk you through how
unity and google are partnering on
making this world
a better gaming place we will walk
through unity's migration
journey and how unity has been managing
scaling and unlocking the power of our
of their gcp environment especially
during
our current pandemic situation we will
also walk through
the behind the scenes story of how
google cloud account
teams and professional services teams
have been
and continue to support unity throughout
this entire
journey before we dive into the details
for those of you who have not heard
about the google
and unity partnership here's a quick
overview from rank
hello i'm venk and i'm a director of
engineering here at
unity we are the world's leading
platform
for creating operating interactive
real-time 3d
content here at unity we believe the
world is a better place with more
creators in it
this is our philosophy and it is at the
heart of everything we do
we want to empower developers with our
real-time 3d technology
to help turn their dreams into reality
unity focuses on giving content creators
a single end-to-end solution
for everything they need to create and
we do that
with best-in-class tools and workflows
that empower content creators to do more
and operate enabling creators to launch
their content
and support it with a full stack of
engine agnostic services
that make things easier for developers
keep their content running
help them optimize it and even monetize
and drive revenue through in-app
purchases
or serving ads to give you an idea of
our scale
three billion apps were downloaded last
year that were made with unity
half of all games are powered by unity
average across
console pc and mobile and those games
and content from many other industries
run across 20 platforms including game
consoles mobile phones
ar vr devices that unity supports
we give developers the power to target
and optimize their content to reach the
widest possible audience
i also want to highlight that our cloud
services usually operate
at over a hundred thousand requests per
second so building a strong gdp
management foundation
was critical to our success
to support unity's global scale and
developer needs
google has partnered with unity for
years on a broad
and significant level across the company
a number of official strategic
partnerships
help part critical elements of the unity
platform
and solve hard problems for the
developers
for example google cloud's partnership
with unity
puts connected games at the fingertips
of all developers
regardless of engine choice they have
access to tools
to build live multiplayer games more
easily
and without needing to be a cloud expert
we also provide the backend cloud for
nearly all of unity's cloud-based
products to run on
stadia and ar core partnerships offer
integrated platform support
to unity game developers that want to
publish to those platforms
with familiar tools and workflows that
make
it easy for them to build ones and
deploy
anywhere admob's partnership opens up
unity's extensive
mobile ad network to google brand
advertisers
and streamlines how publishers with
unity mobile games
can monetize their apps and finally
deepmind leverages unity for research
platform
to run large-scale simulations in
virtual environments
to accelerate ai and machine learning
research if you go a layer deeper
into all of these partnerships a key
factor
driving success is how well google and
unity teams
collaborate on everything from product
development and capacity planning
to technical support co-marketing
campaigns for product launches
and much more this mindset is especially
true
of google cloud's partnership with unity
in relatively short time we joined to
kickstart the connected games initiative
that i just mentioned
and as part of it co-founded open match
an open source project created to help
game developers
solve the tricky problem of matchmaking
which is matching the right players
together
in a live multiplayer environment we
were
thrilled to release the production ready
open match 1.0
earlier this summer gcp infrastructure
also helps unities multiplay a game
server hosting
platform scale into the cloud when
needed
to support new game launchers and
unexpected player demand spikes
this was the case last year when respawn
launched the battle royale game
apex legends 50 million
gamers went online to play in the first
24 days including 1 million
in the first 24 hours flexibility
was crucial gcp helped multiple
scale quickly into into its servers
in seconds not ours with zero downtime
unity simulation and unity game
simulation
to exciting new cloud-based products in
open data also run on google cloud
allowing unity to accelerate
product development and operate both
servers
at scale
all this amazing work that google cloud
and unity have achieved so far
started with migrating unity's
infrastructure
onto gcp unity's philosophy
of democratizing game development is
synonymous with their vast
and distributed engineering footprint
with
key development hubs spread across three
continents
this pose a unique challenge for the
migrating teams
to work cross-border towards a single
goal
to support this geographically
distributed migration
the professional services team was quick
to bring together
amazing individuals across the globe who
ensured
not just technical presence in each of
unity's development hubs
to provide technical assistance and
guidance but also
to be close to unity's team and partner
with the teams
during the migration and also celebrate
together once the migration was
completed
we completed the entire migration over
the course of nine months
the key here is the first three months
we spent
on discovering strategizing and planning
the migration
by the end of the third month we had a
clear understanding
of how and when we wanted to migrate the
workloads
to minimize any disruption but the
journey
does not end with the completion of
migration
rather it only created a launch pad for
all the future workloads unity was able
to bring on to gcp
we launched apex legends game we just
spoke about earlier
in q1 of 2019 right after the migration
and since then we've been working on
onboarding unity's acquisitions
such as vivox delta dna chili connect
and furious onto gcp
this increased footprint also required
careful planning in terms of capacity in
key markets
both on google side and the unity side
to ensure scaling
when needed we saw the results of this
careful planning
when the number of gamers surged during
the past six months
let's get into some of the details of
how unity
has been managing this large gcp
landscape
with a very agile team i will let weng
walk us through the secret sauce
last year at next we talked about how to
effectively manage
a migration to gcp this year we'd like
to follow up with
what happens once you're running in gcp
this next section will help you
understand how to efficiently manage
a business at scale in the cloud
the first thing to plan for is
continuing the momentum
and engagement you've gathered moving
over to gcp
don't wait to finish up plan ahead
here are some examples of ways we did
that
we re-architected key portions of our
stack to leverage
gcp managed technologies new products
like unity simulations were built
foundationally to leverage gcp
we also worked closely with google to
build our partnership through joint
initiatives
after setting the initial direction we
had a simple vision going forward
with managing our high scale technology
in gcp
manage your operating expenses like you
manage
your revenue this vision was realized in
three strategic
areas gcp organization budget management
and capacity planning let's dig into the
first strategic area of focus
gcp organization i have found
that conway's law provides valuable
insight
into setting up effective technology
organizations
in our context conway's law states that
a system will mimic
the organization structure that built it
we applied this principle to enable
engineering teams
by setting up gcp to mirror the
organizational structure within unity
for us that meant a flat project and
folder hierarchy
where folders lined up with
organizations and projects lined up with
product services
we also automated all these capabilities
so engineering teams were empowered to
own their infrastructure
while at the same time following common
standards
including business level tagging to make
it easy to track
spend and map it to products we
restricted
and automated production access using
slackbots
and provided standard modules that
engineering teams could use to build vms
databases and more finally
we applied conway's law in reverse to
set up our core
infrastructure teams to mirror the gcp
management systems we put in place
this also included establishing a devops
culture within each organization
so they were empowered to own their
infrastructure
and organize in the way that suited
their business
today we have established successfully a
devops group
in every organization across unity
let's move on to our second strategic
area of focus
budget management gcp provides a deep
set of tools to manage enterprise skill
budgets
further enhanced by partnership with
tams let's break this
area down into a few sections
the first section is spend the most
important thing for you to know and
understand is your spend
not just the numbers itself but how it
relates to products
services and technology gcp provides
helpful tools here
for you to regularly review the
breakdown of where your gcp spend goes
using reports once you understand your
spend
you can build custom reports for
leadership visibility
and also to enable your teams to own and
manage their gcp spend
data studio is a great tool here
the next section is to focus on
forecasting this creates the ability for
you to have predictable future gcp spend
here are some simple guidelines tag all
your infrastructure with business
related information
formulate a unit this means creating a
formula that maps your gcp spend to your
business outcomes
in our case an obvious one was the gcp
cost to serve up a single request
and establish that cost as the baseline
we wanted to optimize
once you have a unit create automation
so you can regularly
attribute gcp spend to these units it
also helps to understand your discounts
and credits in order to do this
establish a process of doing regular
forecasting
and do that by integrating it into your
business planning processes
it also helps to have a cross-expertise
working group to manage and optimize
this forecast
finally plan and commit gcp
provides helpful tools to commit
including gke committed usage discounts
bigquery fixed slots and more for you to
be able to commit you need to have an
effective planning methodology
look to align with your business
strategy
the last strategic area of focus to
cover in managing gcp
is capacity planning this lets you plan
ahead for any cloud technologies you'll
need to scale into
and collaborate with google ahead of
time here are some key points
work with google to understand your
region's zone and skew limits
use forecasts to plan for capacity ahead
of time
communicate these forecasts and capacity
needs with google ahead of time
and iterate consistency and
predictability is built by doing this
regularly
this year the pandemic has become a
critical and disruptive facet of our
lives
as the world quarantined at unity we saw
an increased engagement with games from
players across the globe
here are some ways we planned for it
from the get-go we focused on staying
ahead of the scale
the last thing we wanted to do was
disrupt the player experience due to our
inability to handle
traffic during these times this meant
focusing on our users and their
interactions with our systems
and staying ahead of potential issues
our central
infrastructure teams double down on
their focus on gcp
in particular sre and the engineering
teams with ownership of high scale
services
this also led to proactive collaboration
with gcp
to plan for upcoming scale needs
finally and i consider this to be so
important
as our engineering teams focused on
handling increased scale
we also double down on our focus on
their well-being
it's easy in such cases to feel like
it's all hands on deck
but it is equally important that your
engineers focus
on their personal health and well-being
and that they feel supported by their
organization
in doing so i encourage you to be
intentional in planning for this
these philosophies on managing
enterprise scale and gcp have worked
well for us at unity
and i look forward to hearing from you
on how it has helped you too
thank you venk for really giving us a
good
uh view into how unity is managing their
operations on gcp
so in this last bit today in the
presentation we're going to talk about
how
on the google side we are enabling unity
success and
behind the scenes and the first part of
that what we want to talk about is the
shared goals that
google team and unity had laid out at
the beginning of
our engagement together uh and how we
have continued it through the
uh through the years um you know the
google pso team and the broader customer
experience are including our csm team
and support team
and unity had taken a shared goals
approach to
uh this relationship which has
ultimately resulted in
shared success and has also helped unity
in its bigger mission of empowering
creators across
industries and around the world setting
up this shared goal was really really
important
because that led to the creation of our
joint success framework that
uh i want to talk about uh because you
know this was really really important
again to enable and making sure
unity is successful on gcp the first
pillar of the joint success framework is
the deep engineering partnership
unity engineering and google engineering
are tied to the hip
um and not you know in engineering
interactions on a daily basis
is the norm and that's how we have
managed for the last two years
which ultimately leads to unity uh
you know shaping a lot of the google
products that you know
and influen really strongly influencing
our product roadmap
um unit engineering and google
engineering again partner on
open source contribution as well uh open
match and
is one of the well-known open source uh
contributions that we have had jointly
there's many more that we're kind of
working on um
and then finally anand talked about the
apex legend learned
a launch like that would not be
successful if we do not do proactive
capacity planning for each workload that
we are on boarding
and each launches that are happening and
proactive capacity planning
understanding the requirement
making sure those regions and the zones
like we are planning through the
capacity has really really been helpful
um for unity to scale up on the platform
so that's all on the deep engineering
partnership that we have across these
different attributes next part of the
pillar is the professional services and
unity interlock
the pso team has been working as an
extension of the unity team
for the past two years what that means
is some of the team members globally
working on unity
account has actually spent more time at
unity than they have at google that's
how close
and we are to to the unity team and
that's how pso is working with them for
the last two years
secondly a lot of our internal developer
tools
is already integrated with the developer
workflow for unity
which means that um you know we have
been able to foster a lot of
collaboration between the two teams
and the tams have been primarily really
really important to enable that
collaboration
uh third piece is what the tams are
enabling is
many many multiple product management
sessions for each of the existing
products and what's coming down the pipe
i know you saw in the deep engineering
partnership where i talked about how
unity is shaping
um our product roadmap that's been
enabled through these product sessions
which the tenants are driving and
doing each and every quarter and finally
the other thing that are the tams really
help is the wall room setup for each of
these critical launches like when a new
game launches and again talking through
the apex legend launch they had 50
million users in 24 days that
i talked about like to manage that scale
we need to have
wall room things always might go wrong
so you know setting up this wall room
for every critical launches is really
really important
the third pillar of the success
framework is enablement and learning
that means gcp training is well
integrated into the curriculum of
unity's internal learning path
that means each and every engineer who
touches gcp
has to kind of gets upskilled on gcp
and i'll talk about how what we are
doing from our side to enable further
training within unity
uh right now we have over 100 engineers
community already taken multiple classes
and we are aiming to almost double the
number this year
and then finally unity and google are
always partnering on imaginism
event like for example this is one of
these sessions
but then also we have participated
unity's
event which is unite and jointly
presented so uh overall we are always
kind of sharing our
story with the broader world through
separate evangelism events
and then finally the last pillar of the
joint success framework is the strong
exec or sponsorship that we have from
both sides
uh we have executive level um
leadership councils that meet annually
or buy annually to talk through how
things are going and reviewing
the broader partnership we have
quarterly technical reviews each quarter
to assess the partnership goals and also
plans to work out the priorities for the
next coming quarter
and then more tactically there is weekly
program management saying
for strategic alignment and making sure
what we are doing on a weekly basis is
aligned to what unity needs at the
moment
so all this put together creates the
joint success framework
um that has and almost talks about the
engagement model we have with unity that
we have taken over the last two years as
unity has given migrated and scaled up
on the platform
next i'm going to uh talk about
particularly
how customer experience or within google
has been helping um unity begin behind
the scenes enabling all the things that
you uh that
that that you saw um i talked a little
bit on tams the tans are working on the
long-term success and advocacy and
bringing the product expertise and best
practices to unity team
we have three tanks aligned globally
right now who are supporting unity day
in day out
as they scale up on the platform second
uh point and i'm going to double click
on this in the next section which is
a foundation and training which is kind
of again enabling unity on gcp just from
a skill
perspective third is a very important
piece which is the google
customer reliability engineering program
we call it google cre program and the
cres are basically x google sres were
customer facing
and our cres have been partnering very
closely with unity's sre team to design
for reliability
operational readiness around particular
applications that we are onboarding
as well as making sure we are
configuring platform signals so
we are proactively getting alerts when
potentially something might go wrong in
the future uh this has been a very very
critical element of
making sure unity has a great customer
experience on the platform just being
proactive about these things
and then lastly again i touched upon
this a little bit which is the co-live
and the critical
event support every time we are setting
up war room making sure we have planned
the capacity making sure there is
dedicated support engineers
looking at the matrix as unity goes live
either on a with a game or with a
particular workload
finally the global support operating
model our support team operates 24 7.
each and every unity p1 cases is
responded
within 15 minutes making sure that you
know there is somebody looking at it
every time something critical happens
our support team is getting more and
more context aware that means that
they know the architecture unity is
using they know the different
different scenarios and the different
use cases unity has
so that they can come to a resolution
much quicker this is done through
creating shared operational playbooks
and customer context and
the cans are playing a key role on
making sure our support team is
completely aware and has context on what
unity is doing so all these elements of
customer experience coming together
again
is key to making unity successful on gcp
the last piece that i'm going to focus
on now is uh
again i talked about this in the last
two sections already
which is training and training at scale
unity is a pretty
large organization they have hundreds of
engineers
and making sure those engineers are that
they know gcp
and skilled on gcp is really really
important so google pso is collaborating
constantly with unity
and partners to deliver at scale on the
learning objectives of
we have already taken 100 engineers our
aim is to almost double the number
uh we are identifying the training needs
we are creating customized courses to
make sure that
they are fit for use then footwork
purpose for unity's engineering org
we are doing multiple coordination and
scheduling across the blue because again
they are very decentralized in terms of
the engineering presence
across the world uh we are enabling
sessions and then
we are also with sponsorship from our
leadership kind of enabling the team to
even get certified on the platform so
we've definitely trained over 100
engineers now but we are also looking to
double the numbers
in coming months so all in all i talked
about the different elements behind the
scene that google
is doing to make sure that unity is
getting successful on the platform
obviously it has taken a village to make
the customer successful
these are all the team members who have
worked day in day out
across the globe in different regions
trying to make sure that
uh unity uh scales up on gcv
successfully
it can help his partners launch games on
the platform successfully and
also overall have a good operational
experience so
uh again all of them couldn't be present
in this session but i just wanted to
call out that it takes a village to
support a large enterprise account like
unity
so thank you to everybody here who has
uh
successfully from google side who has
helped support unity's journey over the
past
two years so massive massive kudos
so that brings us to the end of the
presentation today
thank you for listening to me ananth and
bank as we
went through the unity stories and how
they how the how they have scaled up and
are managing operations on the platform
uh thank you so much for joining us
today uh
and all the best thank you